president trump suddenly signed a
coronavirus relief bill that he
threatened to derail just last week the
president confirmed his move
last night in a statement that
criticized china and the democrats
and he repeated his claim that the bill
is full of waste
and does not give people enough direct
help mr trump also approved a larger
spending package that was needed to keep
the government running
running paula reed is traveling with the
president who is spending the holidays
at his mar-a-lago resort
paula good morning good morning vlad
after days of pressuring lawmakers to
increase these payments to americans
president trump caved to pressure from
both sides of the aisle and just signed
this bill as
is but this delay has already resulted
in a lapse in unemployment benefits for
some americans
with the president's signature millions
of struggling americans will now get
some help in extended unemployment
benefits and continued protection from
evictions
at the same time the government averted
a shutdown
it was a sudden shift just hours earlier
the president had retweeted a video of
his demands for lawmakers
to more than triple payments to
individuals increase the
ridiculously low 600 dollars
to two thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars
for a couple in a statement released
after signing the bill
the president insisted congress will now
be moving forward on his demands
writing i have told congress that i want
far
less wasteful spending and more money
going to the american people
in the form of two thousand dollar
checks per adult
and six hundred dollars per child but
that's not what the president just
signed into law president trump has
remained on the sidelines through months
of negotiations
on sunday morning members of both
parties called on him to just sign the
bill as
is what the president is doing right now
is unbelievably cruel
you don't get everything you want even
if you're the president of the united
states
the president has remained mostly out of
view since he landed in florida to spend
the holidays
but cbs news captured him at his palm
beach golf course sunday
where he played for three of the past
four days i feel
powerless in many ways mr trump's change
of course on covid relief is welcome
news for unemployed americans like javon
anderson furloughed in march he and his
wife are counting on this assistance to
help pay their rent
and medical bills for their daughter we
had to visit a lot of food banks
which we still do we had to visit a lot
you know places that were giving out
toys
you know just to try to keep things
normal for her in exchange for signing
this bill
as is the president has only received
assurances for process for reviews or
possible votes
not any actual policy changes a vote was
already scheduled later today in the
house to try to increase these payments
but last week republicans blocked a
similar effort
and based on the reactions we've seen to
the president signing over the past few
hours
it does not appear that enough
republicans have changed their mind
to actually get the president what he's
demanded tarika
paula thank you me